on parle souvent les opérations charme
des chefs en campagne électorale bien
imaginer à winnipeg au manitoba
on peut même parler d'opération
séduction un groupe organise des
rencontres express entre les candidats
et les électeurs
un peu à la manière du speed dating oui
philippe leblanc nous dit si charme
opère déterminée pour qui voter parfois
une tâche bien difficile en fait beauté
ce n'est peut-être qu'un flirt une
amourette
d'un côté il y à des aspirants
politiciens qui tentent de vous séduire
pour obtenir votre boîte tandis que de
l'autre il ya des électeurs en quête de
l'âme soeur
l'âme soeur politique bien entendu
s'inspirant du concept la chambre de
commerce de winnipeg organise des
séances de rencontres express du
candidat thing en anglais afin de
vérifier si l électeur et candidats sont
compatibles c'est vraiment que ont pu
savoir avec chacun d'eux que souvent
quand les caisses des gens chez nous
c'est malheureux mais c'est le soir
avait préparé il ya des enfants comme ce
soit un peu tendu devrait être le
demander les questions du site
c'est l'occasion rêvée d'aborder des
sujets tout aussi romantique que
l'économie les infrastructures ou encore
l'avenir de statistique canada
pour l'instant ce type de rencontre est
surtout destiné aux gens d'affaires
tous semblent y trouver leur compte
l'histoire parcours ne dit pas si la
chimie s'est opéré et s'il ya eu des
coups de foudre politique